hey guys how's it going so I'm about to
start packing because we are heading to
Utah and I'm so excited we're gonna be
doing a hike of the canyons we're going
to visit one of the state parks I don't
actually know everything that we're
going to be doing so stay tuned but
first uh I got a little something in the
mail
definitely not many of you guys know I
am completely obsessed with the new
amiibo we got dr. Mario I love just
think yesterday all of these guys to
Mario Kart so I could wear them as suits
Bowser jr. mmm smells like delicious
plastic so I'd never played Pikmin until
recently and I can't believe how fun
this game is these are just tuning up
let's go add you to the rest of your
friends
I'm out of space to put the amiibo like
there's nowhere to put them
I need to add another shelf right here I
don't know how to do that maybe I'll
just put you guys down here by Yoshi
until I figure out how to make another
shelf definitely out of space
can somebody lose any weight on a cut
wood alright time to back what happened
here ah that's me trying to pack the
time to 609 our flight is supposed to
take off at 8:50 but I think it's
delayed I'm not packed yet and this is
not good this is not good let's set you
down and let's get packing shall we
I've got emoji pants just because
basically it's gonna be two days of
hiking so I don't really need any other
clothes I'm not packing any makeup and
sunscreen jacket I'm glad I have my
priorities straight it's like do you
want to miss your flight or do you want
to have a different band on your Apple
watch fantastic you look great lookin
sporty
so off the air but we go it is now 7:30
what I don't remember the last time I
checked in with you guys it knows
everything after dinner
now 905 I'm not sure where than the day
way we did a lot of stuff we did cooking
videos today I made a group cake okay I
don't know what I'm doing
how you feeling bulchek gross
there she goes
ah he is answering tmartn yeah so a lot
of people been having trouble because
they can't travel with their mana Rovers
and we just let some died in the airport
cruising around in his mana Rover and we
need to know how because I want to bring
it to Brie's wedding I'm so excited I
can't pay you guys look so dumb on them
I just honestly like I just want you to
know that I am well aware but I can not
stress enough how much fun it's like on
the board I think man I look idiot and
then I fall down fall down boom she's
getting me in fall she's getting me in
town
there she goes
he is answering you guys we got a treat
for you
I'm so embarrassed because I was so
afraid to go and talk to a stranger with
a monorover Suzy goes over some of you
guys may or may not follow one by Kenny
Hollander I've actually seen a bunch of
his own anymore this is amazing oh hey
sir it's how are you oh my gosh this is
so random okay tell me about your board
yeah yeah
just rocking the gliders at the airport
it's great that's great wow you have a
lot of lights on yours
this is great if you had any accident
couple accent it's holding from going
too fast though you know you guys have
to be slow you wear a helmet no we're
getting helmets because she's fallen way
too many times skinny if you're watching
this video you're awesome
Kenny is an absolute problem with this
my mother defaulters lighter we call it
a mottled over I can call you the
hoverboard there's so many names wider
it is different differences are dying
but mine's gonna be camera almost so
many versions of it though
we're finally underway with the fungible
officer plane as they close in saline or
can't wait what time is it it's like
9:00
how did you choose
oh you're fun
there's about like ten people
the times it turns out time travel time
china 7th 1007 find the year where did
this day go do you think we will jump on
the bed
of course
look at this we're walking not monter
oving not gliding we manage of Salt Lake
we're here it's 12:30 ish Jen time Jack
[Music]
it's late we didn't check any bags so
thankfully we can just roll out dude the
most important thing did I packed you
did perfect so we should be able to
survive two days whoo two boxes of glass
perfect for three people we got to hotel
and I said I was gonna jump on the bed
but I'm really tired uh but I said I
would do it I can't wait through the
Bistro tomorrow morning I need the
coffee already I can't jump on the bed
because I will hit my head jump little
little jump little John little jog okay
bye we'll see you when the adventures
start hope you guys are doing well bye
[Music]